thank you
[Music]
finally some good news all right
um we got another young mom in Michigan
how old is she she's 23. but she's
already out of the retardation phase
which is good at 23 I really like that
you said that no don't
[__] already put that in a box and
just hold it dear you know Safeguard it
hasn't even been 30 seconds so it's a
different type of 23. okay that's gonna
be the Callback of the day hold that
what no take it back to Michigan she's
23. she's always said she has problems
with her knees dislocating
what how
yeah I know patellar dude yeah she has
what's called meniscus slipperosis
surgery mom did it's common very
expensive congrats yeah thank you I her
shoulder also comes out of socket what
the [__] is happening and they just
can't figure out man she needs to take
some glucosamine
she sounds like a [__] old-school GI
Joe and someone just kept going like
this and twisting the elastic band
stretch down shoulder is just like
constantly
popping out of socket
um and also [__] David elsewhere the
smile you have when you tell these
articles lines that her jaw like she has
problems like with the way it moves what
the [__] is that she's possessed isn't
she no she's not possessed but like she
just know like her whole life she's like
what is up with my jaw like why is it
like that yeah she got TMJ yeah
it's really really strange and also to
top it off her heart rate's always
really high what is happening
uh yeah she's always just wondered why
am I like this why are my knees doing
this why is my shoulders she doesn't
know she ever been in a car accident no
no accidents at all ever yeah
that she knows of yeah she has a high
heart rate yeah it to me it sounds like
a little bit of uh eating a lot of stuff
she's actually not obese okay it sounds
like she has a disease yeah sounds like
something's wrong with her heart
okay here just so you know like here's a
visual that's her
great right she's triple jointed I don't
know what the body looks like Zoomed In
by the way yeah I zoomed in so you don't
see the title of the article oh or the
shoulder so here's what happens she's
like I'm female Pinocchio she's 23.
she decides to go get this checked out
finally she's like I need to go see
what's going on with myself my knees
keep getting dislocated uh suggest
running her through some very specific
checks did they do the like they hit her
knees it doesn't work oh yeah it keeps
slipping and avoiding it
what do you think she's got oh this has
got to be some unique autoimmune disease
you would think
something to do with physical structure
like loose ligaments of some sort kind
of yeah it can be it can be uh is it a
common disease
actually actually very common yeah trust
you huh
because I don't know what the there's a
term for uh I don't know what the actual
term is if like when people are like
hyper flexible because there is a theme
where it's too flexible like being
double jointed close it's close to that
people they can do like without
practice practicing splits they can do
more than splits it's close to that it's
it's like a it's kind of a Kamasutra
expert in our last life yeah that's what
it was but it's different when you got
yourself there you know when you're like
a Russian ballerina and you can pull a
bow and you stress yourself there like
you've had control and built the
musculature to get yourself there some
people are just like
um like they're [__] they can just
there's talented twist around me I don't
know there's it's close to something
like that like Jim Carrey I feel like
you got it kind of on the tip of your
head no I was gonna say lupus that's
what I was gonna say what is that okay
some girls get it so it turns out
at age 23 it's not lupus though young
mother Ashley was diagnosed with Down
Syndrome
shut the [__] up down syndromes are
known to be flexible
she had Down syndrome the whole [__]
time wow wait so then when you have Down
syndrome you're you you get joints just
falling apart Down syndrome symptoms is
usually shorter and stockier she's she
has what's called Mosaic Down syndrome
which is a version of down syndrome
where you don't look like you have it
but you have it but what are the effects
everything but looking like you have it
so you have Down syndrome you just don't
look down syndrome
conversations like how does that explain
the [__] can we get can we get a
refresher course on down syndrome always
uh notice that she doesn't she has
communication problems she uh she can't
she can't really understand humor a lot
she she says a lot of offensive things
and doesn't realize it she has all the
social characteristics for everyone
that's simple out there there's always
someone that's gonna love you no matter
what you know what I'm saying oh there's
a lot there's some funny like reels that
pass by me where there's some Down
syndrome girls with very nice bodies and
then they're like calm down if you're
down
what does your Instagram look like
comedy
it'll pop up it'll be like it'll be like
a like a girl like she's like got a nice
body and she's dancing clearly Down
syndrome right they're like doing
cheerleading stuff and then in the
comments It's the funniest [__] ever so
I'm down if she's down they'll be like
down syndrome jokes yeah you know hey
comedy comedy baby they're like butt is
butt so it turns out out of her six
pregnancies three of her kids have had
Down syndrome Mosaic down syndrome's
regular she got six she has six kids no
she's had six pregnancies six
pregnancies all of them were
miscarriages
uh she I think three of the kids were
born and and all of them are she lost I
think the other three but they but then
even the ones that were miscarriages
they were diagnosed as having Down
syndrome before they were born
because we got there's like a test that
they do
for it yeah so I'm a little off for that
stuff oh does it cost more yeah you
could pay a fee but some people they uh
they like it where it's like surprise
your baby's down you know some people
they don't care about gender reveal or
whatever they just go let nature take it
you take that test after pregnancy no no
during during like but it's still in the
beginning I mean after getting pregnant
yeah yeah yes yes you just gotta do down
payment oh my God
it looks so good though it's so good
I think your eyebrows can go there he's
got Mosaic Down syndrome right now is
there something that you want to tell us
from the article I want to see what she
looks like though I want to see if it's
she looks like the pictures
you have like the facial characteristics
of someone with with Down Syndrome
really but with Mosaic you just don't
show it I don't know you get slippery
meniscus yeah it's like you have a lot
of weird tricky things with your body
that make it really hard to you know but
there's like a lot around her daughter
so because she has Mosaic it's basically
like you have the same uh when someone
with Down syndrome's having a baby
there's a 50 chance the baby will have
Downs three of her kids uh her baby
looks Downs for sure it's not okay
shoot ass baby by the way I love of
course yes here we go hold on it's just
the statement double down right now it's
just the statement that's all it just
caught me off yeah syndrome babies look
the [__] cutest they're really cute
she's really cute Joe you basically said
this is a table and we're like no [__]
we know
but she looks like a platinum albino
Beauty Downs okay yeah with the blue ass
she's really cute so she has three kids
one of them doesn't have it but the
other two do but what if the other one
was mosaics I I think they they did a
test keep an eye on the knees so what
happens is they do a chromosome test and
if you have an extra one then you have
when do they do the chromosome and how
do they what usually you want usually
you want extras that's that's the test
that she did on herself oh I see the
doctors recommended doing a chromosome
test to see if she might have Mosaic and
it turns out she does but then um you
know her her one kid does not have uh
Downs of any sort I see there's a 50
chance anytime she has a baby that the
kid will will take that in Mosaic dude I
didn't know that was even I don't even
know that was okay no clue that it was
so crazy so again to review those
symptoms as she lived with was her knees
would constantly dislocate her arm her
shoulder would pop out of socket all the
time her jog was crazy uh her heart is
always like at a higher rate and then
and then combined with all those social
difficulties like she can't
um she just can't read cues the same way
you know
you can't understand like nuances but
she looks like totally like oh I'm sorry
I just pop that out of socket
she looks like a you know yeah
non-downsy normal girl I was looking for
the term and I'm glad you said that you
can't tell I wonder what the husband was
like just like you know maybe being
attracted to her but like not not really
getting the social cues from her all the
time but still being down oh not down
[__] down to be in a relationship I mean
he might be autistic and they both are
just like eh yeah I don't get these
jokes you know like who knows Mosaic
autistic maybe he got Mosaic too yeah
because dudes be like hella socially
like unintelligent they're just whatever
yeah dudes are dumb you're making it
happen dude they're like yo she hot
that's all I care about she also has
trouble with short-term memory which I
didn't know was a thing too yeah
but she said so do the rest of us yeah
that's true
yeah very true yeah yeah she's she's um
Ashley wanted to encourage people to get
uh what's called genetic testing and
that's the way that you figure out if
you do have an extra chromosome if
you're if anyone's experiencing these
same things I see I might have it I
might have a couple extra chromosomes a
couple extra couple you look like you
have them
my knees are okay she hopes to create a
community of Mosaic Down syndrome that's
cool super cool oh hell yeah I want to
see that show
oh